my day starts just like yours when I
wake up in the morning I check my phone
and then I have a cup of coffee but then
my day truly starts it may not be like
yours because I live my life as an
artwork picture yourself in a giant
jewelry box with all the beautiful
things that you have ever seen in your
life
then imagine that your body is a canvas
and on that canvas you have a mission to
create a masterpiece using the content
of your giant jewelry box once you've
created your own masterpiece you might
think wow I created that this is who I
am today then you would pick up your
house keys walk out the door into the
real world
maybe take public transport to the
center of the town possibly walk along
the streets or even go shopping that's
my life every day when I walk out the
door these artworks are me
I am art I have lived as art my entire
adult life living as art is how I became
myself I was brought up in a small
village called 4 Longley in England and
it was last mentioned in the Domesday
book so that's the mentality I was
raised by my grandparents and they were
antique stealers so I grew up surrounded
by history and beautiful things I had
the most amazing dress-up box so as you
can imagine it started then I moved to
London when I was 17 to become a model
and then I went to study photography
I wasn't really happy with myself at the
time so I was always looking for
escapism
I studied the works of David LaChapelle
and Steven Arnold photographers who both
curated and created worlds that were
mind-blowing to me so I decided one day
to cross over from the superficial
fashion world to the superficial art
world I decided to live my life as a
work of art I spend hours sometimes
months making things my go-to tool is a
safety pin like this they're never big
enough and I use my fabrics time and
time again so I recycle everything I use
when I get dressed I'm guided by color
texture and shape I rarely have a theme
I find beautiful objects from all over
the world and I curate them into 3d
tapestries over a base layer that covers
my whole body shape because I'm not very
happy with my body I asked myself should
I take something off or should I put
something on a hundred pieces maybe and
sometimes I do that I promise you it's
not too uncomfortable well just a little
you might have a safety pin poking at me
sometimes and I'm having a conversation
with you so kind of go off it usually
takes me about 20 minutes to get ready
which nobody ever believes is true
sometimes so it's my version of a
t-shirt and jeans
when I get dressed I build like an
architect I carefully place things till
I feel they belong then I get a lot of
my ideas from lucid dreaming I actually
go to sleep to come up with my ideas and
I've taught myself to wake up to write
them down I wear things till they fall
apart and then I give them a new life
the gold outfit for example there was
the outfit that I wore to the houses of
parliament in London
it's made of armour sequins and broken
jewelry and I was the first person to
wear armor to Parliament since Oliver
Cromwell banned it in the 17th century
things don't need to be expensive to be
beautiful
try making outfits out of bin liners or
trash you found out on the streets you
never know they might end up on the
pages of Vogue there's over 6,000 pieces
in my collection ranging from two
thousand year old Roman rings to ancient
Buddhist artifacts
I believe in sharing what I do and what
I have with others so I decided to
create an art exhibition which is
currently travelling to museums around
the world it contains an army of me
life-size sculptures as you can see
behind me for here they are my life
really they're kind of like 3d
tapestries of my existence as living as
art they contain plastic crystals mixed
with Diamonds beer cans and royal silks
all in one look I like the fact that
viewer can never make the assumption
about what's real and what's fake I find
it important to explore and share
cultures through my my works I use
clothing as a means to investigate and
appreciate people from all over the
world sometimes people think I'm a
performer or a drag queen I'm not
although my life appears to be a
performance it's not it's very real
people respond to me as they would any
other type of artwork many people are
fascinated and engaged some people walk
around me staring shy at first then they
come up to me and they say they love or
absolutely hate what I do I sometimes
respond and other times they
the art talk for itself the most
annoying thing in the world is when
people want to touch the artwork but I
understand but like a lot of
contemporary art many people are
dismissive some people are critical
others are abusive I think it comes from
the fear of the different the unknown
there are so many reactions to what I do
and I've just learnt not to take them
personally I've never lived as Daniel is
more the person I've lived as Daniel is
more the artwork and I've faced every
obstacle as an artwork it can be hard
especially if your wardrobe takes up a
40-foot container three storage units
and 30 boxes from Ikea and and sometimes
it can be very difficult getting into
cars and sometimes well this morning I
didn't fit through my bathroom door so
that was a problem what does it mean to
be yourself people say it all the time
but what does it really mean and why
does it matter how does life change when
you choose to be unapologetically
yourself I've had to face struggles and
triumphs whilst living my life as art
I've been put on private jets and flown
around the world my works been displayed
in prestigious museums and I've had the
opportunity there's my grandparents by
the way now the people that raised me
under REM
so I've been put on private jets laying
around the world and yeah it's not been
that easy because at times I've been
homeless Levin spat at I've been abused
sometimes daily bullied my entire life
rejected by countless individuals and
I've been stabbed but what hurt the most
was being put on the worst-dressed list
it can be hard being yourself but I
found it's the best way there's the
worst rest as the quote goes everyone
else is already taken
I've come to realize that confidence is
a concept you can choose I've come to
realize that authenticity is necessary
and it's powerful I've tried to spend
time being like other people it didn't
work it's a lot of hard work not being
yourself I have a few questions for you
all who are you how many versions of you
are there and I have one final question
are you using them all to your advantage
in reality everyone is capable of
creating their own masterpiece you
should try it sometime it's quite fun
thank you
[Applause]